[Música]
no soy una persona con un neutro una
historia extraordinaria es más se podría
decir que a 50 mil 562 personas según el
ine le sucede lo mismo sin embargo mi
historia tiene un significado el cual es
resiliencia cuando yo era niña mis
padres eran muy jóvenes inclusive si
hubieran sido mayores ellos no tendrían
como que una fórmula de criar a un hijo
les apuesto que si un padre viera a su
hijo sufrir éste inmediatamente
agarraría ese sufrimiento y lo volvería
como en un jugo y se lo vería así están
los padres cuando era pequeña a mí me
dio una infección en el oído es más
preciso decir en el oído derecho
como les mencioné mis padres eran
demasiados jóvenes me llevaron al doctor
pero simplemente lo dejaron pasar
conforme fui creciendo mi mamá como mi
papá mi hermano siempre me caracterizaba
como la muchacha distraída de la casa
por las razones que contestaba como que
a la primera a la segunda a la tercera
inclusive a la cuarta vez donde me
mencionaba en mi nombre
los sucesos fueron muy continuas yo
estudio en una universidad en la cual
tenía que asistir a las 4 de la tarde
para agarrar un asiento ingresar a las 6
de la tarde la razón de esto era porque
tenía que sentarme adelante
solamente para poder escuchar lo que el
docente decía
estos sucesos mis padres también lo
notaron y dijeron vamos al doctor me
derivaron a lo que es el
otorrinolaringólogo suena como un
trabalenguas verdad es así
les puedo decir de memoria cuál es el
proceso de una audiometría prácticamente
una biometría es medir la audición de
una persona
al ingresar es un cuadrado donde tú te
sientas y el doctor siempre te pregunta
tú estás aquí tan joven no sé soy joven
pero estoy aquí
me siento me ponen los auriculares y te
pueden decir los sonidos que escuchas
las palabras que tienes que repetir era
como que decir casa casa auto auto a
veces no entendía y decía otra cosa
el día que tuve los resultados de mi
audiometría yo no fui fueron mis padres
porque prácticamente a mí no me
importaba el resultado decía es una
prueba más
al ingresar a mi casa solamente vi a mi
madre abrazándome y me dijo tenemos que
hablar
yo estaba impactado y decir porque que
ha pasado y lo que me dijo en ese
instante fue de que yo estaba perdiendo
la audición
se imagina en estos segundos donde yo
estaba ahí y no sabía el significado de
yo perder la oración de como
y ahora porque había pasado esto suceda
cuando era yo niña
de todas formas continué con mi vida
el doctor me derivó a lo que es unos
lavajes en el oído estaba asustada
realmente por el tratamiento pero
continué y al ingresar al consultorio él
la bajé consiste en inyectar té pero al
inyectar te tienen que ponerte antes
como una
como como un suero para que te puedas
calmar el dolor me lo pusieron la
anestesia la aguja era de este tamaño
imagínense en la primera versión después
en la base la aguja era de este otro
tamaño realmente salí muy mareada de
todos los tratamientos una semana
realmente cansador pero yo no lo hacía
por mí yo lo hacía por mis padres porque
yo ya estaba consciente de lo que me
preparaba el futuro
yo estudié administración de empresas en
una gran universidad en una de este es
un docente muy genial dijo algo sobre la
motivación que es el esfuerzo de las
personas la fuerza de voluntad para
alcanzar tus objetivos y yo en ese
instante me puse a pensar y dije porque
yo había estudiado administración de
empresas cuál era mi razón mi motivo mi
fuerza
y era porque yo quería crear una ong
una ong en la cual podría ayudar a las
personas más vulnerables que existían
en esta razón por eso me encanta hacer
voluntariado
una vez cuando era yo adolescente y a la
universidad fuimos a hacer voluntariado
al huayna potosí en el huayna potosí
escalamos la montaña y recolectamos
todas las basuras que habían ahí todos
los desechos los plásticos las
envolturas de sopa de todos los turistas
estábamos en la cima y yo veía
totalmente todo y lo sentía como fuera
las dueñas del mundo al bajar uno tiene
que tener unos tenis especiales con
huella porque si no te puedes poner
yo solo recuerdo haber hecho este
movimiento y esa ocasión solo me
recuerdo rodar y rodar y rodar
en ese instante donde estaba rodando yo
dije me resbalé el pisé mal me empujaron
pasaron muchas cosas por mi mente
y fue que es lo que sucedió que impacte
contra una roca y medio cuerpo estaba
afuera y medio cuerpo estaba en la
montaña un compañero me agarró y me
hallo
y solamente yo empecé a vomitar porque
el impacto era muy fuerte y cuando que
me dijo que me había impactado un rayo
es muy irónico esta historia porque yo
fui a hacer un voluntariado en pro de
ayudar a la naturaleza
pero todo ese sonido toda esa fuerza del
impacto del rayo y todo el tratamiento
que yo había realizado para que mis
oídos mejorarán
realmente ya no sirvió
porque una vez más qué es lo que sucedió
que toda esta fuerza disminuyó toda mi
audición otra vez
fue un retroceso todo mi tratamiento
como los lleve diciendo que la razón era
esto de mi estudio en administración la
palabra servicio a la palabra estudiar
la palabra crear una ong
el resultado de todo esto fue la
construcción de una tesis la cual fue
motivación e inserción laboral de
personas con discapacidad auditiva
este estilo realicé junto con una
compañera con una de mis mejores amigas
a la cual le tengo mucho aprecio porque
pues tuvo mucha paciencia conmigo
ambas realizamos una pasantía en lo que
se llama en el gobierno autónomo
municipal de la paz en la secretaria de
desarrollo social y justamente en esta
secretaría había la unidad de personas
con discapacidad ven que todo cuadra
todo relativamente es perfecto
en ese instante para realizar la tesis
teníamos la mentalidad de que teníamos
que tener una creación una plataforma en
la cual se les pueda ayudar a estas
personas donde ya no puedan escuchar la
palabra no puedo donde no tengan que
escuchar la palabra tú no puedes tú no
tú no deberías estar aquí
ese fue un instante muy hermoso para
nosotros dos
este año a pesar de que es la pandemia
y muchos de nosotros tuvimos varios
bajones sin embargo para mí fue un año
muy bonito porque mis dos papás no tengo
dos uno que es mi padre biológico y el
otro que es mi el hermano de mi madre me
lo pudieron conseguir un audífono y un
audífono no es nada barato cuesta 12.000
bolivianos
ese momento cuando yo fui al doctor
junto con mi hermano me recuerda que yo
estaba sentada y el señor el doctor me
puso el audífono y me empezó a calibrar
claro me calibra la misión porque tengo
que saber cómo estoy escuchando bien
el señor se sentó en un lado y yo estaba
en el otro lado y me empezó a preguntar
cosas cómo te llamas cuál es cuál es tu
color favorito qué o cuál es tu animal
favorito increíblemente le contestaba
todo mi hermano estaba súper emocionado
al igual que yo porque antes no lo podía
hacer saben antes yo escuchaba o trataba
de entenderse el labio y solamente
podría decirles que eran sí claro ajá
gracioso solamente repetir esas palabras
porque no las entendía yo era así
durante toda mi vida hay ocasiones donde
si me avergüenzo un poco no porque me
contaban historias tristes y yo es por
mi mente solamente podría pasar como que
quiere estar hablando pero está bien
después de ese suceso al llegar a mi
casa es lo más bonito aparte de tener mi
audífono
era que yo pude al fin calentar un plato
de comida a mi abuela y meterlo al
microondas y yo me fui a mi sala y pueda
escuchar él
de microondas
para mí este momento fue hermoso ya que
antes yo escuchaba media hora tarde una
hora tarde
y llevarle la comida a mi abuela
caliente era la mejor sensación del
mundo
era lo más bonito que podía pasarme ese
día no sentía una nieta realizada sólo
llevarle un plato de comida a tiempo
al día siguiente claro estaba un poco
asustada porque esto tengo que manejarlo
con mucho cuidado
voy a caminar por la plaza donde existen
muchos árboles y no saben la sensación
que se se siente al escuchar la brisa
los pájaros
era realmente hermoso para mí
después pasaban los días y pude escuchar
la palabra de mi madre diciéndome ánimo
hija tú puedes
mucho a mi papá y mis dos papás
escuchar los chistes malas de mis amigos
realmente deja una muy buena sensación
porque si no bien no las entendía pues
ahora sí las entendía pero ya me reía
con una razón ya no me olvida por reír
agradezco mucho a dios
agradezco mucho a mis dos papás porque
ellos siempre me impulsaba a decirme las
cosas de no estar sola
agradezco mucho a mis dos mejores amigos
que siempre han estado desde otras cosas
de la universidad incluso recuerdo al
bajar a mi trabajo yo tengo un amigo con
el cual siempre me echas la baba y
merecía y bill tienes que cambiar los
papeles no puedes tener lástima por ti
y gracias a esas palabras de ese amigo
yo puede aprender lengua de señas
me tenía que preparar para un futuro
porque ustedes no saben las barreras
comunicacionales que existen el simple
hecho de entrar a un banco es realmente
muy dificultoso para mí bueno era porque
existe claro una ventana por seguridad
en la cual tú tienes que comunicarte
apenas y algunos no son tolerantes
y simplemente te dicen que parece el
siguiente
el supermercado era otra gran dificultad
para mí
entonces este compañero me dijo cambiar
cambiar los papeles se tú la
protagonista de esto
y así lo hice
agradezco también a una persona en la
cual conocí a el año pasado y el cual me
dijo tienes que ser fuerte y yo te voy a
enseñar a ser fuerte
agradezco esta persona porque me enseñó
la palabra solidaridad me enseñó la
palabra paciencia y me enseñó a vivir la
vida de una manera muy muy distinta yo a
veces me limitaba mucho por este
problema pero increíblemente dio una
vuelta de 360 grados
y ahora estoy aquí atreviendo a hacer
más cosas
si tú necesitas a usar un audífono no
tengas vergüenza alguna
porque esto te dará como que un
superpoder
incluso yo puedo decir que nos podemos
volver como ironman tenemos algo ahí y
no nos pueden mentir
porque ya escuchamos todo
hay algo que esto no me va a quitar sí
pues bien en los siguientes años yo
podría estar totalmente sorda lo cual no
me importa porque tengo ya las
herramientas tengo amigos tengo familia
si estaba pasando hay algo que algo que
no me va a sacar esto que es la sonrisa
que le ayudará a las personas sin
recibir nada a cambio
mi historia tiene una palabra el cual es
residencia cuál es la tuya